[Musik]
das deutsche fußball nationalteam der
frauen hat bei der weltmeisterschaft in
frankreich souverän das viertelfinale
erreicht dank eines 3 0 sieges gegen
nigeria es war die bisher beste leistung
des deutschen teams im turnierverlauf
von beginn an dominant auftritt mit sehr
gutem passspiel 6 verbessert im
passspiel über den vergangenen spielen
was vor allem auch zu verdanken war eine
mutigere spielweise mit einer sehr
starken lina magull die den ball
forderte hielt und damit ruhe ins
deutsche spiel brachte das war ein
eindeutiger fortschritt zu den
begegnungen zuvor
almuth schult sagte nach dem spiel
zurecht die defensive ist fast bei 100
prozent die offensive bei 80 und damit
wären wir bei dem thema der perspektiven
für das deutsche team zum vorschein kam
gestern noch nicht zum einsatz sie wäre
wohl eingewechselt worden wenn not am
mann gewesen wäre oder not an der frau
in diesem fall ihr team hat er diesen
einsatz erspart
stefan kann also noch eine woche ihren
zehenbruch ausheilen und dann vielleicht
tatsächlich im viertelfinale
überraschend früh wieder ins spiel
eingreifen und im deutschen spiel dann
die akzente geben geben noch fehlten
eine gewisse kaltschnäuzigkeit im
abschluss eine gewisse exaktheit in der
torvorbereitung beim letzten pass
und natürlich noch die übersicht und
sicherheit die man als einen der
weltbesten spielerinnen auszeichnet das
spiel gegen die gegner zeigte also dass
es im deutschen team bestimmt bezüglich
der einstellung der fitness und auch das
bewusstsein für den besonderen moment
als ko spiel
das team hat weiterhin kein tor kassiert
neun tore geschossen
das sind zahlen die auch mut machen und
vor allem jetzt mit einer woche zeit in
der das team sogar noch einmal ernsthaft
an einigen automatismen in der
abstimmung arbeiten kann
sollte es im viertelfinale gegen kanada
oder schweden durchaus chancen geben
dass deutschland in die finalwoche in
die haut einziehen kann
[Musik]